peugeot la firme de sochaux n'est pas
tout chez elle par des conflits sociaux
pour l'instant elle joue une partie
importante avec la sortie de son nouveau
modèle la 205 gilles cozanet la 205 que
peugeot commercialisera à partir du 24
février c'est en cas de succès la
planche de salut pour le groupe psa qui
en 1982 a perdu près de 4 milliards de
francs un peu ric est d'abord un
investissement important 575 millions
pour l'étude de la voiture elle 625
millions pour la réalisation des chaînes
de production à paris ensuite sur le
créneau choisi celui des voitures
moyennes qui représentent 64 % du marché
français et un million deux cent mille
véhicules immatriculés en 1982 205
s'attaque en priorité à la renault 5 à
la golf et à la fiat uno
elle compte aussi mordre sur la ford
escort l'opel kadett la renault 9 et
plus surprenant chez peugeot en tout cas
on s'y attend sur l'a104 vieillissante
et sur la 3 105 avec cette voiture
peugeot veut frapper vite et fort en
sortant notamment une gamme complète
sept modèles de la version de base
quatre chevaux fiscaux à la voiture de
rallye à quatre roues motrices qui
devrait être présenté la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]